we're 26 so hear a lot about that before
it happens but it is coming he's going
to talk to us about a freedom of the
press and national security he has some
experience in that area and then in
November we have Nash Ramesh Ponnuru of
national review my colleague at national
review will be will be coming to campus
so you'll see posters and and notices
about about that before we before before
I introduce our introducer we have a
student introducer first speaker and I
just want to say what an honor it is to
have Linda Chavez here with us we have a
wheat the journalism prior only bringing
a lot of speakers three four semesters
sometimes and share them with you guys
and often their colleagues of mine
sometimes they're friends of mine and
this is my very favorite one linda was
linda was my boss for five years she was
my mentor she's still my mentor in a lot
of ways she is my friend and it's a
tremendous honor to to have her here and
share her with you I've written five
books the first one I wrote when I was
working with her but I've written five
books and four of them are dedicated to
people in my family the fifth is
dedicated to her and when I took this
job at hillsdale college when I moved
out here four years ago I thought to
myself I want to do for the young people
of Hillsdale College the sorts of things
she did for me when I was about your age
so it's just a tremendous pleasure to
share her with you and an honor to to
bring her here and with that i'm going
to introduce our formal introducer she
is a senior from morton illinois she's
editor-in-chief of the collegian give it
up for Michaela Bennett
hi everyone thanks for coming out
tonight I want to begin my introduction
by saying I didn't actually write an
introduction and that was because I
followed the advice of ms Chavez to do
who said that she's given a lot of
speeches some commencement speeches and
said that she never writes out the
entire speech she just has a few bullet
points and goes from there so I'm going
to try that out tonight and we'll see
how it goes because I had a long day of
being exposed to his job as I began my
day by having breakfast with her header
in class went to lunch with her got to
chat with her a little bit beforehand
and i'm just going to list you a couple
of things about her interesting nuggets
and by no way is this all-encompassing
so look her up after this she's an
incredibly influential woman and has
influenced me just in our short
discussions today so hopefully I will
expose you to a little bit of that in
this introduction I want to begin that
by saying she is a mother of three and a
wife and very dedicated and I realized
that there are conversations and so
throughout all these things that she's
done she has been a very dedicated
mother and wife to her family and I
think that's really important to note
for all of this room of academics she
originally intended to become a
professor and then decided not to when
she realized some of the harsh realities
of affirmative action and I'm sure she
might mention some of that tonight she
now writes a syndicated column that
appears nationwide she's appeared on
many talk shows and radio shows and
tomorrow she's going to appear on bill
maher so I think that'll be an
interesting experience for her and for
us to watch she was the highest ranking
woman woman in the Ronald Reagan White
House as the director of public liaison
and which was something that was really
neat for me to hear about and I hope
that she mentions at this evening as
well amidst all this she found time to
be a politician she ran and lost a seat
in the Michigan or for senator from
Maryland she was also the first person
to see the Watergate burglar so she told
us about that today which I thought was
very interesting and she's now working
on a short series of fiction about North
Korea
but that's not fiction than that she is
just talking about how she feels about
it she's done an incredible amount of
real-life reporting on it as well so
with that I would like to now introduce
our lovely speaker ms Linda Chavez thank
you
I've given a lot of speeches over the
years I don't think I've ever had two
such nice introductions and by the way
John you did forget your most important
connection to me John is godfather to
one of my nine grandchildren so say he
does he's like my fourth son I I
consider him part of the family and his
wife Faye mian and their three wonderful
children it's great to be here at
Hillsdale I've been here before but it's
been about 20 years and the college has
changed a lot and the one thing that has
not changed are the students now you're
not the same people that were here 20
years ago possibly some of you may be
the children of the students that I
encountered at that point but it is the
same kind of student and the liberal
arts education that is provided here at
Hillsdale is something that is very rare
today it's very rare today an American
academia and so I am privileged to be
here and privilege to be asked to come
back and talk to you and I'm very eager
to talk about a subject that we hear an
awfully lot about these days but
unfortunately the subject generates far
more heat than it does light and that is
the subject of immigration and I will
tell you that I have been writing about
immigration for at least 30 years I'm
actually longer than that probably more
like 35 years I've been following this
field I've done a lot of research
including original research on the
subject of assimilation of Hispanic
immigrants my first book out of the
barrio was about this topic so it's
something that I care a lot about and
I've had a very consistent position on
this issue I had this position when i
served in the Reagan administration I
had this position when Iran is a very
conservative candidate in the state of
Maryland for the United States Senate
and I have the same position today
unfortunately from my point of view many
people now say well she's no longer a
conservative she's certainly not a
Republican she's one of those rhinos
because she wants to welcome more
immigrants into the United
Jason that's the last thing we need well
I'm here to give you a conservative
argument for a change in our immigration
policy and I'm going to talk about it in
terms of the current political scene you
know in 2002 the gallup organization
does polling of various issues to decide
what issues are topical in political
years and that was an off year election
but nonetheless an election year and
they hold you know uh voters and to see
what topics came to the top in terms of
issues that people were concerned about
and in 2002 about two percent of
Americans named immigration as a major
issue of concern to them today the i
think it was CNN that just did a poll
today and it turns out that fifty two
percent of republican voters believe
that illegal immigration is the single
most important issue facing us today now
you have to ask sort of why is this the
reason that's interesting is that we
have had a problem of the illegal
immigration actually it goes back to
when we passed our first laws
prohibiting immigration which was not
until 1924 we've had basically numbers
of people who came across the border
particularly from Mexico into the
country illegally going back in the
1950s there were more than a million
people who came a year illegally into
the United States and that was at a time
when our population was about half what
it is today so that'd be equivalent to
two million today and we have had an
influx of illegal immigrants coming into
the United States but the peak of that
influx was between 1995 and 2000 so if
it was this horde of you know new
illegal immigrants who were coming in
that was causing the concern you would
have expected that in 2002 that would
have been when you saw a fifty-two
percent of people concerned about it
instead we're seeing that
concern today at a time when illegal
immigration into the United States is it
about a 40-year low we have not seen as
few people crossing in illegally over
the last four or five years since the
early 1970s so there's a disconnect
there and I guess you know that's part
of what I want to talk about it now I
think that the reason we're seeing so
much concern now is we have a candidate
who decided to base his whole candidacy
around the issue of your legal
immigration and that is Donald Trump you
know he came out with his announcement
speech in which he said that you know we
were being invaded essentially by
rapists and drug sellers and there might
have been a few good people in there he
conceded but you had a sense that what
he was talking about was a horde of
people coming in illegally to the United
States sponsoring crime in the United
States committing crimes here and that
has raised the issue it has become a
very polarizing issue and so that's one
of the reasons that we're hearing a lot
about that well I'm here to tell you
that most of what Donald Trump says on
the issue is simply wrong factually
wrong whether it's talking about crime
or whether it's talking about the
numbers he's simply wrong across the
board and and I'm going to talk a little
bit about immigration in the history of
immigration to the United States because
you know we like to think of ourselves
I've seen the wonderful posters that I
understand one of the students design
for this speech and it's a picture of
the Statue of Liberty and you know we
like to think of that you know Emma
Lazarus speech you know give us your
tired you're hungry though you know the
what is it the refuse of our teeming
Shores of your teeming Shores it is a it
is a way in which we think about America
as a country of immigrants and it's true
most of us almost all of us came from
someplace else even the Native Americans
crossed the Siberian straits and came
from someplace else this was an empty
at one point and so we are an immigrant
nation and that's been very important in
the 19th century how the immigrant flows
were from Scandinavia from Germany and
from Ireland so it was primarily
Northern Europeans who came in the early
20th century when we had the largest
flow of immigrants coming into the
United States at any given period it was
from southern in Eastern Europe Europe
we had people coming from Italy from
Russia from Poland from Greece paying it
was primarily throughout Southern and
Eastern Europe that the immigrants came
now in 1924 we in fact made a major
change in our immigration policy America
from colonial times till 1924 had
largely been a country with open borders
we welcomed everybody we needed to fill
the country with entrepreneurial people
who were going to do jobs and build this
great nation and so we welcome virtually
anybody who could get here and that
included by the way of people that came
in from Mexico as well but it primarily
was a Europeans who immigrated in the
late 19th century we started to import
labor primarily from China and that
really sparked the first immigrant
backlash there were previously McGann
backlashes there were you know sort of
small backlashes locally important pack
lashes but the first real legislative
backlash came against Chinese laborers
who we began to restrict in the late
1880s and then by 1917 and then 1924 we
began to restrict legal immigration from
Europe and we set up a quota system and
basically closed our doors but before
that if you came to the United States
you came here basically like the
Mexicans and Salvadorans and Guatemalans
and others are coming illegally today
you just showed up you showed up you got
a job
if you've been here it can show that
you've been here a certain number of
years you got to apply to become a
naturalized citizen if you gave birth to
children here they were citizens by
birth and that has been the history of
the country but despite the fact that we
have been this great immigrant nation
we've had a love-hate relationship with
immigrants throughout that period we
love the immigrants of our grandparents
generation and it doesn't matter where
they came from you know at the beginning
of the 20th century we thought the great
immigrants were those Germans and the
Irish who were coming we didn't think
very much of the Italians and Jews who
were coming in the early 20th century by
you know 2015 you have Rick Santorum out
saying you know well my grandfather came
here is a an immigrant but he came the
right way well it turns out his
grandfather came as a seven-year-old
child back during the time of open
borders and so you know he came you know
just like again like the Mexicans are
coming today just showed up and became
an American so we have had this
relationship and if you read in if you
read the history of immigration if you
read what people were saying about
Germans in the 19th century you would
think they were talking about Mexican
illegal immigrants today they would
never learn English their kids demanded
to be taught in German the public was
having to educate these kids in German
schools in fact i was talking to
Professor bruiser earlier and he talked
about his family and how they spoke
german at home even after they you know
even generations have been born here
they were in enclaves that were German
speaking and in fact some of the laws
that were passed in the early 20th
century including prohibition were aimed
at the German community they didn't like
the fact that Germans came here to open
beer halls and suddenly there was public
drunkenness everywhere and so the
temperance movement was also an
anti-immigrant movement so we've had
this history and we're seeing it again
now and so you know what I like to think
about is why is it that despite the
history of being not always fond of the
people are coming now
looking very fondly back the people who
came before why is it we do that well
it's because we are successful at
assimilating people and so by the time
the grandchildren of immigrants are
thinking back on immigration they're
already fully assimilated Americans and
so they think gee the Germans did it
right or the Italians did it right it's
just these newcomers who aren't doing it
right it is because of the strength of
assimilation that we look fondly on the
immigrants of the fast and so I want to
talk a little bit first about the whole
subject of illegal immigration focus a
little bit about who it is that is here
how they're coming what what the
statistics show about this population
and then I'll get in later to how I see
solving the problem of illegal
immigration in terms i said earlier in
terms of the flow of illegal immigrants
into the United States it has virtually
slowed to what it was 40 years ago that
large peak that occurred between 1995
and 2000 that occurred at a time when
you had economic expansion there were
lots of jobs and so immigrants were
coming to do some of those jobs they
were taking some of the low-skilled jobs
which in turn made opportunities
available from some of the people who
had those jobs before to move into
managerial positions now not everybody
that didn't happen to everybody some
people lost out in that game but the big
influx was back in the late 1990s we
reached a peak of about 12 and a half
million illegal immigrants a few years
ago right before the recession in like
2007 that was one that was the peak of
the group of illegal immigrants who were
present in the United States since that
period we've seen a decline of about a
million people a million illegal
immigrants have gone home and they went
home for a good reason the jobs
disappeared and because we have poured a
lot of resources
into making the border more secure it is
now much more difficult to get back into
the United States which is one of the
reasons that we've you know seen that
decline in terms of immigration overall
we focus on it in terms of Latino
immigrants Hispanic immigrants mostly
from Mexico but also from Central
America and that was an appropriate
focus for a long time because Mexico was
the largest source of illegal
immigration and they were also the
largest source of legal immigration to
the United States that has been true for
50 years or more it's not true today in
fact for each of the last two years
Mexico has been number three in
countries sending immigrants legally to
the United States it's fallen behind
China and India now so that it's number
three and in fact there is such a
decline in the number of Mexicans who
are coming that there is a band-aid
overall decline and the mexican-born
population in the United States is now
smaller than it was even five years ago
there's been a large decline in that
population more have either died or left
that are being replaced and some of that
is because Mexico's economy during the
recession was doing you know relatively
well there were more jobs Mexico's birth
rate has declined dramatically over the
last 50 years it used to be the average
Mexican woman had seven children now she
has barely more than two on average so
it is a huge change in Mexico and there
are more opportunities more in Mexico
now even with some of the tremendous
problems that are there so we've seen
that decline nonetheless we have about
11.3 million people who are here in the
United States now illegally well what do
we do about this you know conservatives
say the law is the law these people
broke the law and therefore they have to
pay the consequences Trump would say
they're criminals they've you know
they've committed criminal offenses by
crossing our borders well that turns out
actually not to be true if you cross the
border
illegally if you come without
documentation without permission it is a
civil offense it's more than a parking
ticket but it's not you know
manslaughter or grin you know theft
larceny it is a civil offense that
generally the way our system works for
those kinds of offenses usually have to
pay a fine of some sort in order to
clear your name well there are criminal
offenses if you get caught and get sent
home to wherever you came from and then
cross again that then becomes a criminal
offense and if you're a visa overstay or
that can become a criminal offense but
by and large the bulk of people who are
here illegally have not committed a
crime as defined in our criminal justice
system they have committed a civil
offense so what should we do about it
well Donald Trump and from my point of
view unfortunately several Republican
candidates and now nearly a majority
about forty seven percent of Republican
primary voters think what we should do
is round up these people who are
illegally here and send them home well
let's think about that for a minute
we're talking at 11.3 million people and
by the way Trump says he doesn't want to
break up families so let's send all of
their American cysts and children with
them and those citizens num number four
million people so we're talking about 15
million people what does that mean 15
million people it's a big number how can
you think about it well you can think
about it this way I'm from the state of
Colorado we have about a little over
four million people in our state so we
have to get rid of everybody who's in
Colorado it would be equivalent to doing
that and we'd have to get rid of
everybody who is in Ohio to come up with
numbers that would be equivalent to
sending home essentially 15 million
people think about what that would do to
our economy five point six percent or so
of the labor force in the United States
the workforce is comprised of people who
are in the country illegally they're
doing jobs that Americans won't take at
least not you know presently people
don't want to work on
chicken processing lines they don't want
to go pick tomatoes in the hot Sun I'm
not going to go pick peaches on the
western slope of Colorado or milk cows
or do a lot of the jobs that illegal
immigrants are doing and so you would
have a decline the estimates are you'd
have a decline in the labor force of
about eleven percent it would cost in
the gross domestic product about 1.6
trillion dollars and the cost of
rounding up everybody and getting them
home when we do have laws you know we
are not you know Germany in the 1930s
you can't load people onto cattle cars
and send them where you want to send
them we have due process even for people
you'll here illegally and so you have to
go through the system and the estimates
are it would take 20 years to process
and because we are capable of processing
about 400,000 people a year and it would
cost between 400 and 600 billion dollars
so I'm here to tell you this is not
going to happen and those people who
think it is going to happen you know are
not thinking straight and frankly if
they live in communities where illegal
immigrants are working and living they
really don't want it to happen because
if it does is going to depress property
values stores are going to go out of
business they're not going to be selling
to the people who are working and by the
way if you're there I see a few gray
hairs in here and my hair is gray under
miss clairol you know I'm on Social
Security I certainly don't want those
people to leave because they're
contributing a whole heck of a lot of
money to the Social Security trust fund
like 12 point six billion dollars a year
in payments that illegal immigrants are
paying into the system they're paying
more than 10 billion dollars a year to
the Medicare Hospital Trust Fund so they
are supporting part of that social
welfare net that some of us who were
born here be fortunate enough to be born
here again so I don't think that's going
to happen
and then the question is what do you do
about it well I have two responses to
that everybody says well you know you
have to enforce the law well
conservatives say that but they're not
real fond about the idea of enforcing
Obamacare you know nobody is saying well
it says right here on page you know 743
subsection B you know part to that you
have to do such and such and by golly we
got to do that because it's the law of
the land no we say as conservatives it's
a lousy law and we ought to repeal it
and change it well I believe that the
laws that are on the book now that go
back to the mid-1980s on immigration are
bad laws they are unenforceable they are
essentially big government and big
brother wedded together and writ large
probably you don't even know this but
those of you who are out doing jobs I
hope that whoever has hired you even on
a part-time basis for a few hours a week
has asked you to prove that you are in
fact entitled to work I hope you had to
produce your passport or your birth
certificate in order to get that job and
if you're an employer even if it's
somebody who's cutting your lawn you
know once a week or maybe you know your
work and mom and you've got some help
around the house you better have filled
out an i-9 form and not only should you
fill it out and make sure you've checked
the documents but you better file it
away and keep it for three years and if
you know Mary doesn't work out and you
have to get rid of her and hire Susie
you better make sure you keep Mary's
papers for three years and then you have
to fill out new papers for Susie empty
those for three years and on and on and
by the way the people who want to solve
the illegal immigration say well what we
really need to do is to make it harder
we have to make sure that people call
Washington DC and get permission from
the federal government to hire somebody
that's a really conservative idea this
is you know this is the solution how are
we going to keep people from high
illegal immigrants we have to turn every
single employer in America from the
smallest to the largest into supplicants
to the federal government and get
permission from the federal government
before
we can offer a job to someone to me
that's not a conservative solution so I
have a different alternative we have to
do something about the 11.3 million
people here and in fact there was a
compromise it wasn't a perfect bill the
Senate bill that was the so-called gang
of eight bill that Marco Rubio and John
McCain and others sponsored it certainly
was not a perfect bill the Democrats
were able to throw in a whole bunch of
junk that had no business being in there
and would make things even worse but the
main provisions of the bill seemed to me
a proper solution as I said illegal
immigration is a civil offense people
who came here illegally if we're going
to bring them out at the shadows umber
and normalize their status here they've
got to pay a fine now when George Bush
George W Bush was in office he proposed
that that find be about twenty five
hundred dollars a person that's a
substantial amount of money and he also
suggested everyone would have to go
undergo a background check and in fact
the the gang of eight bill required that
as well and people would have to
demonstrate that they have paid their
back taxes that they had in fact been
contributing members and had paid their
taxes and in fact again most people
don't know this but about two-thirds of
people who work illegally in the United
States already pay their social security
tax their Medicare tax that's how we
have those excess contributions many of
them if they earn enough also pay income
taxes and even though they don't have
social security numbers because they're
not entitled to them unless they're you
know have phony Social Security numbers
they the IRS they could care less
whether you're legal illegal born here
not born here you know if you landed
from the moon they just want your money
so they are happy if you show up to you
know apply for an employee
identification number they are happy to
give you that number and they are happy
to take your cash and to take it out of
your checks and to collect it so most of
the illegal immigrants who here are
already paying tax but some aren't some
are working for unscrew p
lyst employers are working under the
table and so those those taxes should be
collected I happen to be an agnostic on
the subject of whether or not those
who've come here illegally should be
given citizenship or not I personally
favor citizenship because I think it
ties people to the country I want
everybody to want to be an American but
I could live with a compromise that said
if you broke the law you're going to be
able to stay here you're going to work
here you know get right with the law but
you're not going to be able to become a
citizen your children are going to be
citizens but you're not going to be a
citizen I could live with that and by
the way most illegal immigrants could
live with that they've actually been
pulled their been numbers of poles on
this the Pew Research Center has done a
lot of pulling on this and
overwhelmingly what they want is the
right to live here in peace to be
contributing members of the society and
not to have to worry that they're going
to be you know disappear overnight and
be picked up and sent home while their
families are are here so I think there
is a possibility of a compromise there
but the most important part of fixing
this problem is taking a look at what to
do about our legal immigration laws back
in 1986 President Reagan was confronted
with than four million illegal
immigrants and he decided to give true
amnesty he didn't ask for a fine he
didn't ask for criminal background
checks he just said basically you show
you been here this long you get to stay
and he did that as part of a package
that was coupled with the immigration
reform and control act which enacted
what I consider these draconian measures
that I think are very non conservative
that asks that make employers including
individuals have to ask permission to
hire somebody that make them have to
gather all this paperwork and keep track
of it and you know essentially they can
you know become just as you know much
criminals or civil offenders as the
illegal immigrants themselves if they
don't keep those records so I think that
law needs to be scrapped and I think
what we need in its place is a new legal
immigration program that basically is
based on what I consider
to be conservative principles these
principles are that you know we believe
in markets markets work employees are
actually much better at deciding how
many people they need to bring in to
feel certain kinds of jobs then the
federal government is that some
bureaucrat in Washington is in 1986 we
set a number on how many immigrants we
were going to be admitting you know for
the next it's 1986 that was 30 years ago
the numbers you know having fluctuated
much we've had one or two changes we
have little minor changes around the
edges but it's still this idea of
Washington driven we now spend more in
terms of enforcing our borders than we
do on all other criminal law enforcement
combined people who say we're not
spending enough we spend 16 billion
dollars on enforcing the southern border
we only spend 14 billion dollars to
combine on the FBI alcohol you know
Tobacco and Firearms the Secret Service
that the Drug Enforcement Administration
the US Marshal Service all of those
other law enforcement agencies combined
do not equal the the budget of what is
spent on border enforcement so it isn't
that we're not spending enough money
that we're not building enough walls the
walls aren't big enough we've got to
figure out a way to use and put market
principles to work so that we admit
people of the kind of people that we
need and we do it in an orderly fashion
and it's flexible you know when we've
got eight or nine percent unemployment
we don't need to be bringing a whole lot
of people in because there are a lot of
Americans out of work or a lot of other
immigrants who are already here out of
work so we don't need to have huge
numbers then but when the numbers go
down or when there are needs in certain
industries like agriculture like meat
processing at the low end and like the
high tech jobs at the top end we need to
bring those people in and it ought to be
skills-based it ought to be based on
what our needs are and it ought to be
flexible so that as I say
numbers and bad years with more numbers
in good years and we also need a system
where we don't necessarily bring in
everybody to become permanent residents
here we create a guest worker program we
had a pretty successful guest worker
program in the 1950s I didn't have time
or I couldn't carry it on the plane but
I have a chart that shows what happened
when the bracero program was enacted and
put into full implementation in the
1950s you had 1 million illegal
immigrants coming in a year then that's
twice as many proportionally is we've
ever had coming in in the recent term
and what happened is we created the
bracero program we gave it was primarily
agricultural workers that were needed in
border states like California and Texas
we gave people the right to be able to
go into Mexico hire people bring them
over have them work in you know seasonal
jobs and then they would home for a part
of the year and what happened was from a
million a year it dropped in the very
first full implementation year to 65,000
that's over ninety percent drop we could
do that again so the way to in my view
fix the illegal immigration is to make
it easier in terms of our needs to be
able to bring people in Legally on a
temporary basis or on a permanent basis
and I think you know that would have a
major impact a far more effective impact
than trying to build walls or hiring
more agents or putting troops on the
border all the things that really we
don't have much of a hit of a history
and and I think frankly would be a
problem but in doing that we have to
make sure of one thing and that is that
when we bring people here we do what
we've done so well in the past and that
is we assimilate them they learn English
now you know it's really funny because
people do think that you know their
grandparents all learn English not
necessarily but the children that were
born here or if the kids were young when
they came they went to public school and
they learned English
and so usually within a generation or
two they assimilated and when you look
back for example at the Italians there's
huge number of Italians who came in the
early part of the 20th century a lot of
people don't know this but a third of
them went home they didn't make it it
didn't turn out it turned out they
really didn't like it here was too hard
and they went back to to Sicily or or
the main part of Italy but the ones who
stayed over a period of time didn't in
fact move into the middle class and into
the mainstream but it took Italians 70
years from their peak year of emigration
to when they caught up with other
Americans and education levels it didn't
happen overnight it happened over time
well the good news is that in terms of
Hispanic immigrants they are actually
doing it faster than has been done in
the past Hispanic immigrants are in fact
they're learning their learning English
the more than I think it's ninety seven
percent of second-generation Hispanics
that is Hispanics whose parents were
immigrants speak English fluently that
is their predominant language the
majority of them get their news in
english you know the Univision's and the
tella novellas and some of the programs
that you see in in areas where there are
large Hispanic population it's the
elderly people who are watching that
it's grandma who's watching the
telenovela or maybe mom it's not the
kids who are in school they're not you
know they want to be watching you know
the shows that their classmates watch so
they learn English and this is despite
the fact that liberals for several
decades have tried to stop them from
learning English I was a big opponent of
bilingual education for for many many
years and you know got a lot of enmity
in the Hispanic community for that not
among the immigrants because they
understood their kids they didn't want
their kids cleaning toilets and you know
picking grapes they wanted their kids
going off to be engineers and they knew
that in order to do so they had to get
an education and
have English but the middle class
Hispanic advocacy organizations and
groups did promote Spanish language
instructions so that kids weren't back
segregated and sent to you know learn
their lessons in Spanish but even
despite all those efforts it had worked
very well they will ultimately do learn
English but they've also done some other
things that are quite remarkable when I
started writing about this issue and
started doing research into the Hispanic
population and my first book came out in
1991 there was a pretty substantial
education gap between Hispanics and
non-hispanic whites Hispanics really
lagged in education they didn't go to
college a very small proportion went to
college about twenty percent or less and
there was about a twenty percent gap in
terms of high school graduation rates
even among us born Hispanics and I was
concerned about that and one of the
interesting things was part of the
reasons they didn't go into school is
they had a very strong work ethic and so
kids would graduate high school in and
or maybe they'd be a junior or senior in
high school and they'd find out they
could make fifteen dollars an hour
working on a construction site and they
lived in big families and mom or dad
said can I go down and get a job you
know we need the money we're going to
want to buy a house we want to start a
restaurant we want to start a
landscaping company you go out there and
you know get a job and so that was one
of the things that was sort of
deflecting well that's not happening
anymore and in fact the recent
statistics on second-generation
Hispanics the children of Hispanic
immigrants is that there are high school
graduation now lags two percent behind
that of non-hispanic whites that's
nothing statistically that's that's the
margin of error practically so it means
that we basically close that gap and for
Hispanics who actually graduate high
school two years ago this trend started
more of them actually went on to further
post-secondary education the
non-hispanic whites you know go figure I
don't know what happened maybe the jobs
that the construction site dried up and
so the you know parents said well you
may as well go to the junior college now
they're not graduating from four-year
colleges in the same numbers as
non-hispanic whites there many of them
are going to two-year colleges but from
my point of view that's not necessarily
a bad thing because if they were going
to four-year institutions many of them
would be going on the basis of
affirmative action and they'd be ending
up in schools where their grades and
their test scores really wouldn't allow
them to compete so they end up going to
schools where their preparation you know
prepares them for it and you know they
then may finish that to your degree and
maybe they'll go on to get a four-year
degree so they're closing that gap
they're closing the income back half of
all Hispanic immigrants own their own
homes you know this is not a welfare
dependent population that we have to be
worried about for generations to come
they're really really doing very well
and the ultimate test of assimilation in
my view is intermarriage when we talk
about the melting pot the real melting
pot happens when people of different
ethnic backgrounds intermarry and for
the Germans and the Irish and the
Italians and the Jews that didn't happen
for generations it really took a long
time before you saw that kind of mixing
now it's happening rather quickly again
with second generation Hispanic children
of immigrants about a quarter of them
will marry non-hispanic whites and among
the college educated about half do so
that's going to be the ultimate melting
ground and in fact some people have
pointed to the fact that there seems to
be a kind of drop off in the third
generation some of the statistics don't
look as good for the third generation as
they do for the second well this is a
phenomena that happens to be true of all
immigrants whether you're talking about
Chinese or Indian sore or Mexicans for
that matter and some of it is that the
children of immigrants are very
motivated their parents have struggled
very hard to get here and so they work
very very hard but another factor that
may account for it is that some of those
third generations who have intermarried
they may be the product of an
intermarriage they simply drop off the
screen because they no longer check the
box they know no
longer self-identify they're just
Americans and so the most successful
ones we may be losing in that
statistical pool well let me end with
this thought immigration it's a tough
issue it's always been a tough issue
it's always been a divisive issue it's
no different today than it was in the
past but it is also not so broken and it
is not something that is so difficult to
fix you know that it is comparable to
you know taking a flight to Mars or a
brain surgery it's not rocket science it
is something that is fixable but we have
to have the political will to do it and
that means people being willing to stand
up and say what they believe in just
what they're against but what they're
for and it has to be done in an
atmosphere where we're not demonizing
people who are coming here you know if
you live in a small village in Guatemala
or Mexico or El Salvador or you know a
town in China or a village in India and
you want a better life for your children
you're going to want to come to a place
where you can build that life and the
fact is that in America we have always
been the country that welcomed those
people and the reason we are the
greatest country in the world in my view
is that we take the best and the
brightest you know Donald Trump said
well Mexico is not sending as top 1%
that's true no country sends the top 1%
the top 1% in every country they leave
their do and find they have no reason to
want to leave it's the people who are
sort of in the middle or even in the
lower part but the people who are risk
takers think about how hard it is to
leave a place that's familiar to you to
go to a country where you don't speak
the language where you may not even know
anybody where you're not sure that you
can get a job or that you're going to
place you know be able to find a place
to live think about taking that job on
the poultry processing line having to
cut up chicken parts all day long 48
hours a day standing on your feet
difficult hard work and think about
what it takes to be that person it's a
special person it's a person who has the
kind of motivation to be able to make it
and by the way one of the other things
that trunk talked about was crime you
know he said they're all criminals and
rapists etc well there is a relationship
between immigration and crime in the
United States it's an inverse
relationship the higher the immigrant
population in an area particularly in a
low-income area the lower the crime if
you charted crime in over the last 40
years in the illegal immigration you
would see illegal immigration going up
until recently yet see crime going down
at the same level is this just a
coincidence well it turns out they've
actually been some studies that have
gone into communities to try to find the
answer to that and what they find is the
reason the crime goes down is that the
people who come here are those special
people their parents their a father
trying to make a better life either to
send money back to the village wherever
he came from or to provide money for the
children who are born here they're out
there working they're not out there
preying on other people and by the way
they're not on welfare they're not
eligible for welfare if they're illegal
immigrants their children may be
eligible for things like free lunch
programs and from my point of view too
many of them are put on those roles but
I think that's a result of government
wanting clients and they go out and
actually recruit people and a little you
know why nita goes to class and you know
they find out that her family earns less
than the poverty line so they put her on
the free lunch program who's going to
turn that down nobody's going to turn
down free stuff it's just not in human
nature but the problem if we have a
problem there is to attack the welfare
system and the welfare rules it's not to
attack the people who are coming here to
try to make a better life so I want to
leave you with just one thought and that
is a thought from Ronald Reagan's
farewell address you know he talked a
lot in his presidency about the shining
city on a hill and I'm sure while some
people might not know the origins about
you here at Hillsdale know that it goes
back to John with Winthrop in 1630 and
it goes
even before that to the Bible to the
Sermon on the Mount but Reagan invoke
that image all the time and he chose in
his parting speech his farewell speech
the last speech he gave president of the
United States to talk about what that
image meant and he said something that I
think is very important and frames what
I believe ought to be our immigration
policy he talked about that Chinese city
on a hill and he said if there had to be
city walls the walls had doors and the
doors were open to anyone with the will
and the heart to get here that's the
America that I believe in I think that
is making America great again is by
enacting that kind of policy thank you
very much
I'm happy to take questions so and I'm
sure there are some I hope there are so
yes I did especially kind of glossed
over to primary realities first and
foremost about the freedom teaches us
that we can't have a welfare state a
know the borders and I think that you
have to choose one of the other and its
most importantly I think that's the
America my great grandparents immigrated
to it was a lot different than the
America every sentiments are immigrating
into today I grew up in Southern
California I went to the public school
system there and I my classmate kinds of
classmates and early or events and what
do they talk history class they're
taught America is an evil country that
the founding fathers were racist and I
the mexican-american war they took very
ancestors lands and they deserve her
they deserve justice today and I and my
great-grandparents on the other side
were taught America is a great country
they were installed for work ethic so
absolutely you have hit the nail right
on the head and I think this is one of
the greatest causes of fear today but
it's a problem I mean it is a problem
that has a solution the problem in the
solution the problem is not the
immigrants in the solution is not you
know slowing down immigration or sending
people back home the problem is the
welfare state I don't like it the 47
million people are on food stamps in
America today people are not going
hungry it's a freebie and again it's the
Obama administration has created a huge
client state I mean you know I can't
remember the guys name there was a
scottish maybe some one of the
professor's helo know who i'm talking
about but i think he was a contemporary
of Adam Smith but he talked about
democracy in the trajectory of
democracies and he talked about what
happens in
in democracies is is at a certain point
when everybody's voting they start
voting themselves benefits and then who
that's it Alexander Tyler so they start
voting themselves benefits and then
pretty soon you know Mitt Romney wasn't
wrong we have a you know large chunk of
the American population that lives off
government in one form or another and I
count myself as one of those people as a
Social Security recipient I have paid in
at the highest levels most of my working
career but my mother lived to be 90 if I
live to be that old I will still collect
more in benefits than I ever paid in it
is a transfer of wealth from the working
young to the elderly so we have become
this nation of takers and we are no
longer you know builders so yeah we have
a problem the problem we have to hit
that problem but the problem is the
welfare state let's attack the welfare
state on multiculturalism I couldn't
agree with you more I have been a you
know I've been booed off stage as I've
been denied the right to give
commencement speeches because of my
views on this issue and the last time I
spoke at Hillsdale it was about
multiculturalism and the threat to the
American Way that multiculturalism posed
because the fact we are an exceptional
country we do have certain beliefs and
values and those must be transmitted to
the young but the problem isn't so much
your classmates I mean they're a
fraction of the population what about
all the kids you know Johnny Smith and
you know and Susie Jones they're getting
fed this nonsense too and so it's the
entire problem of our education system
and multiculturalism that we need to
attack yes absolutely you know I don't
want to be you know taught that you know
that my forefather you know of well my
family came here before Mexico you know
even exist as an independent nation they
came to what is now the United States so
you know but if I don't want my children
taught that the President of Mexico
should be their hero and that they
shouldn't look up to George Washington
or Abraham
Lincoln because you know he they were a
bunch of dead white guys it's a problem
for the entire society and
multiculturalism is absolutely something
we need to stop and we need to stop
pushing but it's not immigrants that are
pushing for that it is native-born
Mexican Americans who created bilingual
education programs so that they could be
you know given an extra stipend for
teaching those classes it was not the
immigrant parents and in fact John
Miller and I worked on campaigns to try
to end those programs in the state of
Colorado in California and elsewhere and
it was the immigrant parents who were
the bedrock of opposition to bilingual
education because they didn't want their
kids scrubbing toilets and picking
tomatoes so yes we have those problems
but those problems are not the
immigrants problems they are our
problems as a nation and we have to
attack those problems if we had never
had another immigrant come into the
United States again for the foreseeable
future the welfare state would still be
a problem and so would multiculturalism
yes in the back
thursday is supposed
well I think there's a lot of
misinformation and lack of information
out there I think when I go out and I
spend most of my time speaking to
conservative groups trying to persuade
them on this issue and I fit some
success actually they're surprised when
they hear the numbers often you know the
skeptics will say where do you get your
numbers you know Anna I say well I get
them where everybody gets their numbers
you get them from research organizations
you get them from the Census Bureau you
know the people who gather statistics
but there has been resistance but I
think the biggest problem is economic
anxiety what I find when I speak
particularly to older Republican groups
they're worried about their grandkids
they're worried about whether or not
they're going to have jobs now I always
ask the question well do you really want
your child to work at the pilgrims pride
processing you know chicken and to a
person they almost always say yes but
believe me they don't want their child
doing that or the grandchild doing that
and you know the chances are we could
pick up those jobs we could transport
them to Mexico I happen to have sat on
the board at pilgrim sprite for five
years and those jobs can be sent to
Mexico but you know that's not going to
help the people who are in these
communities then you know the people who
rent houses are going to have you know
no tenants and the people who sell cars
are going to be able to sell cars and
the stores are going to have fewer
customers so that's not a solution but
it is that economic anxiety and the
second thing is the question you know a
part of the question that was raised
initially people really dislike having
to press one for english they don't like
that this is our country i mean even
come set down bush shouldn't beast me
out we should speak english well again
this is a fact of life and it has always
been true of immigrant groups they don't
learn english immediately takes a while
they didn't learn it when they were
speaking German or they were speaking
Italian they don't learn it as quickly
as we'd like when they're speaking
Spanish the important thing is their
children are learning it we should make
it absolutely imperative that their
children be taught in English so that
they will learn
english and in terms of an immigration
program I would be forgiving points in
an immigration system that gave points
for English fluency there's a lot easier
to you know get a job if you speak
English and it'll be a better job than
if you don't and frankly anybody who
spent any time you know in the tourists
parts of Mexico there are plenty of
english-speaking Mexicans they can you
know people learn languages so I think
those are the two things that are
driving it more than anything yes
the Lord
yeah take back
taken from
and then probably is not just Hispanics
but some other groups that have come
also this
well i think you know you're right
married there is that problem but again
it's mostly fueled by left-wing third
generation PhDs at UCLA and USC and
other places that are promoting this and
baton passing out the Mexican flags and
the Salvadoran flags and the whole
multicultural movement feeds into it
absolutely when kids go to school in the
old days they used to want to become
American but you know when I lived in
purcellville Virginia which is a rural
area and i went to the july 4th
celebration there were lots of immigrant
workers there in both in construction
and in some of the farming and
agricultural work there and you know
what i saw around me were you know
little Salvador and Guatemala and
probably Mexican kids waving American
flags so you know we still have some of
that and it is there it is a problem
that i think it is fed by the elites i
don't think it is so much the immigrants
one of the things about los angeles i
talked about crime a minute ago in the
inverse relationship los angeles which
used to have terrible crime is now one
of the 10 safest big cities in america
and in fact of the 10 safest big cities
and that's defined by a hundred thousand
or more population seven of them are
cities with very large hispanic
populations and all but one of them are
in fact border states so there you know
the population is not as fearsome as a
lot of people worry about and think
about i know we hear a lot about gangs
gangs of you know again been part of the
immigrant experience going back to the
the gangs of new york i don't know if
any of you saw that movie that martin
scorsese movie but you know that was
about gangs at the turn of the century
so yeah there are some problems but
overall it's not been a negative
experience it's been a good one but that
doesn't mean we shouldn't make sure that
our public policies promote a simulation
and that's why i would give points for
people to learn English yes
your conversation today lecture will and
go ahead my question is going to go to
something that you did mention a little
bit more a little bit more about what do
you think about this so there's been
instances of Primus taken place
obviously spurring the legislation
senator Cruz well rights law etc there
my question for you then is since the US
Constitution affords US citizens rights
to due process and so forth with as
federal government protecting our rights
of citizens would you extend due process
to those criminals of you that are
illegal in the country or in fact would
you favor ice attention in the
deportation force well it isn't really a
matter of what I favor or not it is a
matter of law that they do have due
process rights even illegal immigrants
have due process like rights under our
laws anybody who is here even if on a
temporary basis even if here illegally
has a certain amount of due process that
is due them do I think that people who
commit crimes and who are illegally
present should be that we should take
care of them I think they ought to go to
a Mexican jail Mexican jails are not
very pleasant places and I would much
rather you know I don't even care if we
you know give stipends to the Mexican
government to house them because it'll
be a lot lower than what it costs to
house them here so absolutely look these
crimes there been a couple of very
high-profile crimes in California it's
disgusting it's horrible these people
shouldn't have been here it is these are
people who were caught who are sent back
but you know it is still possible to get
in I don't know that we will ever solve
that problem we can't build a fence high
enough that people can either come
across and get in a boat go up to Canada
and come down that way or dig a tunnel
under it or frankly bribe officials
there's a lot of bribery that goes on
with the Border Patrol people turn the
other way you know so we're never going
to totally solve it but I am absolutely
in favor of anybody who's committed a
serious violent crime we got to get rid
of them we've got to make sure they're
gone yes
wondering if you describe drug
trafficking and immigration because we
aren't having a tangled mess how would
you untangle them so that you know it is
right well it you know it's very
interesting first of all let's remember
that drugs come to the United States via
Mexico because Americans buy drugs and
use drugs there is a market for them
here believe me they wouldn't be coming
here if they weren't making big profits
doing it interestingly most of the hard
narcotics besides marijuana that you
know the cocaine that certainly the
heroin the you know the really hard
drugs used to come through the Caribbean
and they came in in flights they came in
in boats the Drug Enforcement
Administration was very successful in
cutting off that Avenue but what
happened is that instead of the
Colombians you know picking coca leaves
sending them you know through the
Caribbean and into the United States
that Avenue got stops so now they come
up the land border and they come through
Mexico so what you're seeing now from
Mexico is in part the result of the
success and stopping the trade through
the Caribbean and um you know it is one
of the reasons that I think we should
have a legal way for people to come you
know we let in about six hundred
thousand people a year now hunter on our
legal system but at times when we have
you know high on high employment and low
unemployment and certain jobs that that
we need immigrants to fill we need we
may need a million we made it even a
million and a half if we had a way for
people to come legally they would not
being paying the drug cartels to smuggle
them in so that would dry up a source of
income to the drug cartels and the drug
cartels then could not use those people
as mules to force them to bring in drugs
in turn for getting them across the
border so I think would actually have a
positive impact to have a legal way for
people to come and that sixteen billion
dollars it's being spent I've never
known yet a government program that gets
started and gets funded the shrinks so
my guess is we're going to see that
sixteen billion dollars i'm going to
continue to go up it's not going to get
smaller but how about having that
sixteen billion dollars focused on the
really bad guys the the criminals and
the drug traffickers and the human
traffickers and all those resources
focused on them so I think by solving
the legal immigration problem and
allowing more people to come the legal
way would actually help us in fighting
the drug war as well yes
well the evidence that i sees shows that
we are successful when you ask young
second and third generation hispanics
they identify English as their primary
language that's where they get their
news source they identify themselves as
American first in terms of even
political differences I mean one of the
tragedies from my point of view is a
partisan Republican in the Republicans
new harsh tone is that we're driving
people who would be voting Republican
away you know we've seen I've been
following this for over 30 years
actually going back to the early 1970s
when Richard M Nixon was reelected in
1972 he got about a third of the
mexican-american vote the base for the
Republican presidential candidate has
been the bottom has been about a third
going back you know 40 years the only
time it's fallen below that is when
there is a harsh anti-immigrant tone and
by the way it isn't just Hispanic voters
who didn't vote Republican last time
only twenty-eight percent of Hispanic
voters voted from Romney only
twenty-seven percent of asian voters
voted for Romney and that is a
population that has relieved in more
Republican they tend to be small
business people they're well educated
they are you know the kind of people who
would expect to be voting for lower
taxes and smaller government but because
the party has been identified as
anti-immigrant it's turned off those
voters so I do think that you know the
assimilation still works the problem
with multiculturalism is a bigger
problem than immigration I worry as much
about the you know we got thirteen
percent of the population is immigrants
I worry about the other eighty-seven
percent who are us-born who are being
indoctrinated with it isn't really even
multiculturalism what it really is is
anti-western anti-american it isn't
about promoting the great cultures of
China or India any of these things it's
about tearing down America and tearing
down the United States it's not about
learning about other cultures and
nothing wrong
with you know studying other great
civilizations that's not what
multiculturalism is so solving the
multicultural problem is a major problem
just as solving the welfare dependency
is a major problem it's a bigger problem
for the American born than it is in my
view for the immigrant thank you very
much going to thank you thank you so
much there's only one problem with her
talk um was a part about Ohio you're in
Michigan and you have you have no idea
how much we'd like to deport a bunch of
people from from Ohio jerk George will
George will once wrote a newspaper
called me said for every ten immigrants
we LED and we need to deport one college
professor which i think is even an even
better idea I meant to give away a book
before we start and I completely forgot
while I was up here this is this is
Linda's book is called an unlikely
conservative the transformation of an ex
liberal or how I became the most hated
Hispanic in America I hope she's the
most loved Hispanic in hillsdale tonight
I'll give it to the person who can was
that art is it was up there's a question
there's a blurb at the top of the book
it says a brilliant provocative and
moving book a blend of the personal
often very personal and the political
and this quote appeared in what
critically important national magazine
National Review lippincott gets the book
I didn't write it but but but somebody
did anyway Linda thank you very much
thank you all for coming and we'll see
you for mr. Rosen next month